Jonathan Roush please explain for us the
meaning behind the title of your most
recent book governments and why
Washington stopped working this is a
book about why it is that despite 20
years of concerted efforts to reform
Washington from the top down to make it
a different place if you were Reagan to
make it much smaller government if
you're Bill Clinton to expand health
care and create a big new national
program why it seems to become so much
more difficult to make Washington work
to solve national problems and it
basically argues that the standard
civics textbook view of government is no
longer true that is to say it's
Washington has changed over time
government has changed over time it's
not just the will of the voters anymore
in fact according to this book voters
and politicians these days have less
power than they think why did you write
it this goes back to the beginning of my
career in Washington Doug I've been here
gosh almost 20 years I started out as an
intern at national journal magazine
covering the budget eventually under
Reagan and seeing just how difficult it
was for Congress to grapple with this
enormous budget deficit to spec despite
the crisis situation and then realizing
over time as I wrote about agriculture
and about many other federal programs
that the strangest single fact about
Washington DC was that once you enact a
program you can never get rid of it it's
there forever and that got me thinking
about well gee what does that mean if
you can never get rid of anything then
you can't create but more important it
becomes very hard to act creatively
you're stuck with your first try every
time you adopt a program you have to
live with it forever because some group
forms around it and defends it and it
began to seem to me that what we were up
against here was a much deeper richer
and in some ways more disturbing
phenomenon than the standard view of
government which is partisan gridlock
ordinal wrong party in power then in
fact we're getting an accumulation of
programs that that you can never get rid
of and then gradually government sort of
becomes ossified it becomes tied up or
arterial sclerosis
I use a lot of medical metaphors in this
book and eventually I called the first
edition of it
demo sclerosis meaning the kind of
sclerosis syndrome here in Washington in
fact how much of the book demas
chlorosis was published in 94 and
government send was published in 1999
how much of demas chlorosis ended up in
government's end a fair book bit of it
government send is a heavy revision of
demos chlorosis about five of the ten
chapters are wholly or partly new and
I'd guess probably about a third of the
actual words are new but one of the
things that happen over those five years
between the first book and the second
was that I decided that I was wrong in
some of what I said the first time
around the first book I said the way to
get out of this is with large
comprehensive reform efforts and I began
to realize after Newt Gingrich failed in
a large comprehensive reform effort and
after Bill Clinton failed in a different
sort of effort that that wasn't going to
be possible that in fact the strategy
that works seems to be the opposite of
what I said the first time it seems to
be that you work the margins and slow
gradual but absolutely determine
incremental change and that's how you
get things done in this city not with
big promises of reform
so the message became very different in
this book and of course I was able to
look back on Clinton and Gingrich and
added a great deal more perspective
about reform efforts in the new book the
title of your previous book demas
chlorosis and it's subtitle the silent
killer of American government are a bit
of a harbinger of something that you
were talking about that appears
throughout your current book governments
and that is this idea of sort of a
medical metaphor that continues on page
125 in a chapter titled demas chlorosis
you write demas chlorosis government's
progressive loss of the ability to adapt
is a gradual but continuing process it
is not like an acute fever which attacks
in sudden crisis and galvanizes the
immune system to respond with an all-out
decisive attack it is more like the
hardening of the arteries which builds
up stealthily over many years like
arteriosclerosis you right it can only
be treated by a long term change in
behavior
disciplined regimen of self reform why
the metaphor of disease what are you
saying using that metaphor of disease
that appears throughout your book a
couple of things one is the distinct
resemblance between the one-way building
up process of programs and groups in
Washington that you can't get rid of and
the build-up of plaque in arteries and
in veins and so on a key concept of
governments end and I think a concept
that's probably unfamiliar to most
people who grew up with the standard
civics textbook view of Washington is
that you can't understand American
government until you see that it's got
an arrow of time that is it's in a
one-way process like the human body
which ages we all know in fact we take
for granted that being 55 is different
from being 25 and that they're both very
different from being 10 years old now
that's not the end of the world it's not
tragic that we age it's just part of
human life it turns out that government
is subject to the same sort of
internally driven one-way process it's
not hopelessly bad news but it means
government will never be young again it
will never be able to act with the adapt
Ness and creativity of the 40s or even
the 60s and it seemed to me that the
medical metaphor was a good way of sort
of bringing that home to people
intuitively play doctor for us if you
can for just a moment every disease has
a cause let's first take what aren't the
causes of demas chlorosis one the first
thing that's not the cause is so-called
gridlock standard view of Washington too
hard to get things done nothing gets
done in the city in fact the truth is
exactly the opposite of that doggone
every measure you look at you find
Washington is doing more in terms of
number of pages passed regulations bills
and so on the problem isn't that it's
too hard to get things done it's that as
hard as it is to get things done it's
much harder still by an order of
magnitude to get them undone once
they're done so gridlock misconceives
the whole problem it's like say
that the problem is your car standing
still when in fact your car is going 55
miles an hour but the wheels are out of
alignment it's the whole wrong kind of
way to look at it second thing that's
not wrong
is people say well the wrong party
controls the White House or Congress or
if we had the same party controlling
both branches that would solve it it's
some sort of temporary political problem
which the next election will sort out
one of the things I was able to do in
this new book is look at 20 years in
which we've had almost every possible
permutation of partisan control same
party controlling both chambers one
party white house other Congress flipped
them over almost every way you can do it
we've tried doing as Americans in the
last 20 years and guess what doesn't
make much difference that's not where
the problem was so it's not gridlock
it's not politics is there anything else
that it isn't before we get to what it
is yeah it's not special interests on
the other side of the system it's not
your enemies whoever it is you vote for
it's not the people you vote against who
are the cause of the problem this city
is full of people saying if only my side
won and the other side lost the good
guys would be in control whether that's
Friends of the Earth or the National
Federation of Independent Business or
whoever you favor and then the problem
would go away but in fact that's not it
either
because of course everybody believes
they're the good guy in this system and
everybody is fighting for what they
think is right and what they think
rationally serves their interest and all
of us are part of that system it's
inclusive and that's the secret to its
success it ropes us all and we're all
complicit is that what you mean when you
write in a chapter titled the parasite
economy again we see this disease trope
that you employ you write in Washington
you soon discover everybody is a
selfless public servant not only does
everybody say so but almost everybody
believes it as well exactly you know I
have yet to meet a lobbyist who said
took me aside and said you know John the
truth is I'm out to destroy this country
for my own personal good it's not the
way it works in fact the city is full of
altruistic people if not altruistic
people because they're well paid but
people who believe that their virtue
who believe they're helping the country
and who will always say that they're
defending themselves from the people on
the other side so why is it as you say
in the title the subtitle of your book
why is it that Washington has stopped
working here's the idea in any large
human system whether it's government or
the economy or a corporation or indeed
your ordinary life the way you solve
problems is through trial and error you
try something you see if it works in the
real world if it doesn't work you try
something else
it's called adaptation and of course if
you try something even if it does work
five years later it won't work anymore
because the world will have changed so
you have to be able to use trial and
error and you have to be able to adapt
well here's the problem
suppose you're stuck with every program
to a first approximation that the
government has ever passed right back to
maritime subsidies from 1789 it's
virtually impossible to get rid of
anything for an analogy to that imagine
being a company and you're the executive
of this company you're told it's going
bankrupt you need to save it do anything
you need to do to save this company but
only one rule you cannot eliminate any
product that that company has ever
produced and it's a 200 year old company
so you're still going to be making a
Model T automobiles even though no one
really wants to buy them and they don't
work very well well of course you'd say
I can't fix a company under that rule
that's crazy I've got to be able to get
rid of old things to replace them with
things that work better Washington has
to a very large extent lost that
capability because everything that
exists is so well defended by whoever it
is whatever group it is that depends on
it but it loses the flexibility to creep
be creative to adapt to trial and error
now is that unique to Washington no it's
not it's we see it all the time in
corporations we saw it in the Soviet
economy which had a dreadful case of
this where you could never shut down a
state enterprise because it was plugged
into the government you see Japan having
a very serious case of this problem
today
Japan desperately needs some reforms and
some opening up and it's having a
terrible time getting around the
interest groups that defend everything
but when it happens in a private company
ultimately there's the discipline of the
marketplace which is to say if the
company doesn't reform it fails it goes
out of business well we don't want
government to fail at least I don't and
I think most people don't
we need our government to be stable and
we need it to go on but because of that
and because the federal government's so
large and there's only one of it it's
not subject to as much of this
discipline it can go on this way without
reforming itself without getting rid of
old things virtually in perpetuity
the blame has been put by other
colonists and observers on something
called special interests does the blame
belong on the special interests yes and
no I try to avoid the term special
interests in this book because I think
to most people special means not like me
a special interest is a group that you
belong to but that I don't belong to my
group is national interest take it apart
for us what does special me because it's
a term that appears in your book and in
our in our language as well what is
special mean and what does interest me
well an interest group of course is
something that forms to defend a
particular program or subsidy or need or
whatever it is that they're getting that
they have a particular interest in
defending and of course the original
meaning of special interest isn't
special in the sense of exalted or
different it's just special in the
senses it's of a special value to me now
when you ask your special interest the
problem and I said yes or no that's the
no side but the yes part is if is if you
take out of the equation the idea that
any particular group is the source of
the problem the fundamental dynamic here
is that as society grows older its
subdivides into more and more of these
narrow interests these people looking
after particular programs particular
benefits and as you get more and more of
those things look looked after and
defended they get locked in over time
and societies can rigidify that way so
fundamentally yes the problem is the
tendencies of societies generally and
governments specifically to form more
and more of these client groups that I
often call them on page Emily this is
page 46 and a chapter hyper pluralism
again in your book governments and
you provide a list of just a few and you
lists these here these are what are
often called collective interests the
association of old crows the National
paint varnish and lacquer Association
the opossum growers and breeders
Association the American Association of
sex educators counselors and therapists
the bow tie Manufacturers Association
the association of metropolitan sewerage
agencies and the frozen pizza Institute
why do you list these Institute's in
this book just to make the point that
we've gone way beyond the civics
textbook view of say the 50s and 60s
when you had labor and you had business
and you had a few basic groups that
spoke for most Americans that these days
everybody is organized and groups
continue to form at the rate of dozens
and dozens a month well what's wrong
with that if I'm a bowtie manufacturer
isn't it in my interest to have
representation in Washington absolutely
you can and you should and it's
absolutely a part of what democracy is
about this is a book again to go back to
medical metaphors to a large extent
about side effects of necessary and good
processes in a democracy it is necessary
and good for people to form groups and
look out for their interests and to try
to make society better off as they see
it which is what a lot of these groups
are trying to do the side effect however
is that there's no central control on
the overall number of these groups so
that as they proliferate it's not the
fault of any one group or any group of
groups but it's a systemic problem that
is you get more and more of them it can
become more and more difficult for
policy negotiating makers to negotiate
to move around it becomes like swimming
in a pool full of molasses instead of a
pool full of water what do you think the
public's understanding of we what let's
not use the term special interest let's
use the term you also use collective
interest groups what do you think the
public's view and understanding of these
groups is in one sense it's fairly
realistic I think the public if you ask
them in surveys they'll say that
interest groups have a great deal more
influence than voters and I think
actually in terms of day to day
government that's more or less true but
on the other hand there's a certain
naive to even sanctimony the sense that
special interests are other people are
not me I'm not part of the problem and
they respond to rhetoric like what you
heard from John McCain during the
election cycle which is well we've got
to do something about the special
interests in Washington the fact is
pretty much everyone in this country is
a member of at least one special
interest and most people are members or
active or implicated in many more than
one the problem isn't them the problem
is us and that's why I think the McCain
rhetoric misses the mark just out of
curiosity what would you say are the
interest groups that represent your
interests in Washington as a journalist
well there's the American Society of
newspaper editors there's a magazine
Society I don't I'm afraid I don't know
the names of them because I'm not act
from them there's a congressional
correspondence gallery there's one for
the house and one for the Senate I I may
be in one of those then there's of
course things outside of journalism if
you have a triple-a card for instance
you probably use that to get towing
service but of course they're a group
they lobby if you've got student loans
or if you're paying back your student
loan well there's believe me there's
groups out there to defend those loans
in case someone decides to try to reduce
those and use the money elsewhere you
you seem a little bit more pointed in
the book in the language that you use
this page 91 you write in the public's
mind the standard model of lobbying in
Washington involves special interests
buying influence in a sort of legalized
bribery do you think that's accurate and
is does that accurately reflect what
goes on in this town only to a very
limited extent in fact the problem in
this city seems to me is much less
legalized bribery where special
interests so to speak buy votes because
there are now interests on absolutely
every side of every question and they
are all making campaign contributions to
politicians in fact the problem is more
the opposite which is politicians
shaking down the lobbies going door to
door and saying gee wouldn't you like to
make a nice fat soft money contributions
on my behalf this year because you know
I'd hate for something bad to happen to
your program in my committee so
of what's going on in the money cycle is
in fact defensive and moreover if you
just took the money away altogether as
some reformers dream I think futilely
of doing you still wouldn't change
things very much because these groups
depend on these programs it's their
livelihood it's their life it's their
job if you're a sugar program with
grower you need that subsidy you've
structured your whole life around it you
need it much more than anyone else would
ever need to get rid of it so you're
gonna do everything it takes to to
defend your your program in your
interest and money is is just one of
many elements one of many weapons in
your arsenal to do that is this why you
say that it is a unidirectional process
that it only accretes it only builds up
over time it tends to be a one-way
process what is the effect of that
that's where you get this hardening I
talked about the standard view of
government is that government is a
machine it's kind of like an airplane
and the people are the passengers and
the politicians are the pilots and at
any given moment the government is more
or less doing what the people want it to
be doing in that given moment so it
could get larger it could get smaller
depending on what the people the
passengers in effect tell the pilots the
politicians to do the fundamental
argument of governments end is that that
picture really isn't right it's not
altogether wrong but it's misleading
government is much more like a jungle
that it's evolved so many of these
programs and so many groups each and its
little niche defending its little
program or its big program in some cases
that it's become much more like a jungle
than like an airplane and the
politicians are like elephants you know
they're very big and they can rip up
trees and do a lot of damage they're
very conspicuous but if you really want
to know what shapes the terrain and
what's really in charge from day to day
in this jungle it's all the little
flying and stinging creatures it's the
worms and the bugs and the nematodes and
the algae and the spiders all these
little things that are going on about
their business and no one controls that
the voters don't control it they have
some influence politicians don't control
it they have some influence but mostly
the jungle runs itself
that's what Washington's become so what
does that mean well it means a lot of
things the
first thing it means is when I call my
book governments end I mean end in a
very specific sense not that it comes to
an end but that it's reached a kind of
stable equilibrium a destination point
as it were a point from which it's very
hard to turn back a point from which you
can't unnie volve and the basic meaning
of that is that if you want to know how
government will look very roughly for
the foreseeable future look at it right
now that isn't to say it won't change
very significantly you might have more
spending on defense and more on Social
Security as people get older the
contours of the jungle change but if
you're the sort of person who dreams of
some big comprehensive rationalizing
reform of government you're going to be
disappointed if you're a conservative
who wants to make government a small
town again as the gold water rights and
Reaganites and gingrich heights all
wanted to do it's time to leave the
pumpkin patch and go home no one has the
power to do that similarly if you're a
liberal and you want to go back to the
heyday of the Great Society or FDR make
America's government much more like
Sweden's you can't do that either
the jungle won't let you do it it means
from now on we're talking about a
situation which is on the one hand very
stable which is good but on the other
hand you can only really change it on
the margins if it lets accept the
premise that government slowly becomes
the Washington slowly becomes less
effective in what it's able to do
discuss if you can three recent reform
initiatives that have been a topic of a
lot of discussion in Washington welfare
reform telecommunications reform and
campaign finance reform those three are
all very different one of the things I
try to emphasize in the book is you know
people always hear this and they think
what a gloom and doom but what pessimism
you know what a cheerless wretched view
of the world this author takes you don't
seem like a cheerless wretched well I'm
not and in fact fundamentally I argue
that this is in many ways a quite
optimistic book that what's happened is
over the last 20 or 30 years voters
developed false expectations of how much
you could do overnight and they became
continually frustrated when they voted
for Paula to
who promised huge reforms like Gingrich
or Clinton for that matter and who then
couldn't deliver and that voters are now
wising up to this they're becoming
reconciled to the fact that you can only
change it on the margins on the one hand
but on the other hand and this is very
important the margins matter they matter
a lot if you can pass a welfare reform
you don't change the whole government
overnight but you do overhaul a very
significant program and you do it in a
way they can do a lot of benefit one of
the great things we did in Washington is
in the 70s we deregulated the
transportation industry this had an
enormous ly beneficial effect on a whole
sector of the economy that was something
that Jimmy Carter did for which he
deserves a lot of credit tax reform in
the 80s it didn't last of course because
we cleaned up the tax code and then all
the little groups went back to building
all their tax loopholes back in but
nonetheless for a while there we were
able to sweep it clean we were able to
clean house a very significant and
important reform telecommunications I
would say was has been less important so
far and I know less about it but the
point is that although you can't sort of
take the whole government in your hands
and reform it from the top down you can
go after important key programs and make
them better than that that's what the
game is all about and as the voters
begin to understand that that's the
definition of success not some huge area
forum but specific real reforms of
program that will become easier to do
and that those marginal changes will
become easier and that's very important
you dedicate your book to Mansur Olson
you write to the memory of Mansur Olson
teacher who was Mansur Olson an
economist University of Maryland he died
almost exactly two years ago in 1998
Mansur Olson wrote two extremely
important books which greatly influenced
my thinking in this book the first was
called the logic of collective action
published in 1965 and the second was
called the rise and decline of great
nations Olson argued from an economists
theoretical point of view that any
stable society will tend to accumulate
interest groups
in groups for collective action over
time and that in any society that's free
basically any democracy in which people
can form groups gradually they will he
also pointed out that they're much
harder to get rid of than to form and
thus it's Olson who gives us this idea
of a direction of time in society where
other things being equal you get this
accumulation and build-up this is one of
the central tenets of your book it seems
absolutely largely built on the
intellectual structure that did man sir
Olson put in place in his economic
thinking what he did not do was apply
that thinking to government he was
interested in the role of interest
groups in the economy so he was looking
at cartels he was looking at labor
unions and he was looking at the
economic effect of subsidies and what
could happen to an economy as they
accumulated over time I took that idea
and said now wait a minute the same
process happens to government itself as
it becomes more and more cluttered with
these groups that demand things and that
never go away you mentioned two books
what what's the second book by Olson
that played a role in your evolution of
thinking it's called the rise and
decline of nations if I have been the
title correct it was published in 1982
and that's the book where he takes the
basic insight about the accumulation of
groups and says this could actually help
explain why societies why countries like
Britain through the 50s and 60s seemed
to age and grow old and why it is that
after an enormous transforming
catastrophe like a totalitarian rule
which of course is bad or a great war
why they seem to bounce back and and
come back with additional vigor as
Germany and Japan did after World War
two he said it's because you sweep away
the accumulation of groups and you can
build fresh what are the policy
implications of that theory well Olson
himself was of two minds about it he
liked to say that he was optimistic
every other day of the week he believes
that the key to this was was educating
the public he believed that the more
people understood about this process
that was altering society over time the
more they'd be able to do about it so he
put great hope in education
and in some sense to a limited extent I
follow him in that and that's why I
wrote this book we've had a largely
pathological relationship between the
American public in the American
government over the last twenty to
thirty years where people expect too
much and are constantly disappointed and
I think to the extent that people learn
what's going on here learn why just
trying to elect a McCain who will claim
to drive a bulldozer through all the
lobbies in Washington but that's never
going to work that they'll begin to
focus on more productive strategies that
may be a little less glamorous but will
be more effective and in fact I think
that may be starting to happen in this
year's election is there a certain magic
do you think - the word that we've heard
a lot and that we you and I have used
here reform yeah there's a lot of magic
to it and of course we're all the
reformer with results in in this
election cycle why is that word so
powerful well you know people are
dissatisfied with the federal government
they were quite well satisfied with it
through Kennedy when you asked if they
trusted it to do the right thing
seventy-five percent of them said that
they did those figures began to decline
in the Vietnam days and have never
recovered the percentage saying that
they trust government to do the right
thing is now 20 to 30 very low people
don't really like what they're getting
from Washington they can live with it
but this gives I think reform a great
deal of allure and of course I'm a
reformer - I just argue you have to be
realistic about how much you can reform
in any given year but and you also have
to be realistic about the obstacles to
reform that you know it's one thing to
be for reform in the abstract we're all
for reform in the abstract but in order
to change anything in this city you have
to change some particular program and
that program is structured the way it is
because some particular group is
benefiting from it and because they've
given a lot of campaign money and
because there's a chairman of some
committee or someone from some state who
likes it that way it becomes very hard
to translate these area notions of
reform into the particulars of
governance you've been a journalist
covering Washington for some time now
let's get your thoughts if we can on I'm
gonna ask you about several industries
or activities and their role is as
either a productive element or an
obstacle
in this reform dynamic that you're
talking about let's begin with the media
well you know it's hard to answer that
in that way because a core argument of
my book as you know is that we're all
both on the one hand we're all trying to
reform things in our lives and in the
programs we work with to make them more
successful or efficient from our
personal point of view but on the other
hand we're also defending what we've got
my reform is your obstacle so I think
we're all some of both if you ask what's
been the role of the media in all of
this of course I'm a journalist and I'm
biased I tend to think that the media
actually is much like the voters that
we're not all that different from
anybody else that on the one hand we
tend to like reform in the abstract
we're always for reform in the abstract
but that on the other hand when a
president or a Newt Gingrich comes along
and says he's going to make some changes
in Medicare the first thing we do is
pick up our phones call the American
Association of Retired people and take
down the most inflammatory quote we can
possibly get and put it on the wires and
then write a lead about how President
Clinton's Medicare proposal ran into
trouble today when group XY and Z said
such-and-such so like everybody else in
this country I think we're on both sides
at once the legal profession you know
there you have an interesting case a lot
of what's happened in the last two years
by way of policy reform has come not
through the standards system but through
lawsuits filed by class action lawyers
plaintiffs lawyers often with the
assistance of governments as have
happened in tobacco cases and the gun
cases and if you ask them what they're
doing they'll say well Congress wasn't
doing its job so we had to help Congress
was so gridlocked and so bound out by
special interests that we had to go
around the process to get done what we
wanted to do now this it seems to me is
a cure that's worse than the disease the
founders didn't want it to be easy to
make change and the idea that you can go
around the democratic process and use an
undemocratic one in order to solve these
problems strikes me as exactly the wrong
sort of way for voters and politicians
to vent this frustration I think we're
going to have to work
through the system and change the system
where we can but we oughtn't to be
subverting it is the law then you have a
chart if I can this is from the chapter
again the parasite economy private suits
filed in the federal courts it's a chart
from 1950 all the way to the year 2000
with a bit of a break there and we see
what obviously looks like a steady
increase are you making a connection
then between the amount of litigation we
see in society and the a word that's
used disenfranchisement perhaps voter
from government government there's some
connection in the particular chart that
you refer to I'm making the broader
point that as societies age they tend to
devote more and more of their resources
to people who struggle to claim existing
resources it's called transfer seeking
it's called my lobbying to get more of
what you've got or my suing to get more
of what you've got and that this
transfer seeking activity although
everyone involved believes themselves to
be doing the right thing for themselves
and for the country it's actually very
expensive because there's so much cost
as people fight back and forth and I was
counting lawsuits and lawyers as one
very crude indicator we have that
suggest there's a lot more transfer
seeking industry going on in America
today than there was say 40 years ago I
don't want to dwell on this too much
because there's a lot more in the book
than just this but again returning to
this question of looking at industry's
role perhaps as either positive role or
obstacle what about think tanks think
tanks are to my mind not much of the
problem if at all now I say that perhaps
self-interested Lee because I'm a writer
in residence at the brookings
institution which is Washington's oldest
possibly largest think tank but ideas
are not like federal programs they come
and they go you can always put more
ideas on the table and the more the
better you know you have genuine
pluralism with ideas one of the good
thing that's happened in Washington I
think in the last 30 years or so has
been the great proliferation of points
of view in this city we now have think
tanks all the way from the far right
through libertarian Center all the way
to the far left putting up position
paper
making points-of-view known and I think
that that more information adds insight
to the system so my view is that the in
the ideas industry on for change you
have something that's really not very
much part of the problem I think Senator
Moynihan once referred to them as the
idea factories finally what about the
public relations industry well again you
know these things touch all of us I have
a sister in the public relations
industry and like everyone else they do
what they do if I could broaden your
your inquiry and answer it slightly more
broadly the PR industry is one facet of
one of the really important developments
in government's in the last 30 years
which has been the professionalization
of the lobbying class you know it used
to be
there weren't many lobbyists in this
town there are a few thousand they all
knew somebody and lobbying actually
meant you know you go and rub elbows
with some congressmen and you play golf
with them and maybe you slipped them a
little campaign money while you were at
it
that's that model is ancient history
lobbying today does mean you do a little
of that but much more than that it means
professionalized grassroots activism it
means you've got these enormous
specialty lines where all you have to do
is press a button into your national
headquarters and they'll generate phone
calls in any congressional district in
the country where you want to try to
swing a congressman's vote and the PR
industry is part of this
professionalization you now have image
shapers who will tell you exactly what
you need to do to save your program if
next year President Clinton decides to
put in his budget that he wants to
reduce the budget and you've got this
enormous infrastructure built up now
people who do this for a living that's
another thing that's never going away in
a democracy we're going to have to live
with that very efficient very
professional lobbying sector so if you
say I believe you say the government
that we have now is the government that
we essentially always will have and we
have this explosion in the number of
lobbying groups in the number of
collective interest organizations public
relations industry advances 10 20 years
from now what is what are the
implications for American governance
implication number one is that
fundamentally thing
won't look all that much different than
they do now though government will
always be changing for months a month
people are very busy in this town
changing things on a sort of microcosmic
level if the macrocosm won't look all
that much different but it also means I
think and here we get to the message of
what we can actually do about this I
think it creates possibilities for a
more effective reform style if you'll
allow me to go back to the yet another
medical metaphor suppose you're getting
older and you go to your doctor and you
say I'm old and I'm tired and I've got a
heart condition and here's how I'm
dealing with it I'm sitting on my sofa
complaining about getting old and twice
a year I go on a crash diet which
doesn't seem to work your doctors likely
to say that's not a very effective
approach to ageing gracefully and
successfully he's likely to say what you
need is a regular moderate program of
exercise you need to watch your diet you
don't ever expect to be young again you
know you can't sit on your sofa
bemoaning the loss of youth but you can
understand that you can age much more
gracefully and retain much more vitality
into old age if you keep at it if you
work slowly but surely on diet and
exercise and healthy habits and the same
is true of government I think if we
focus on incremental reforms of the sort
that we can do and have done
successfully for the last 30 years
government never gets young again but we
can keep it vital enough so that to a
first approximation it will do many of
the basic things we need to do little
right Social Security checks fairly well
we'll be able to work around it to a
considerable extent and in fact to an
extent we do that already with things
like charter schools and that all of
these things mean that none of this is a
disaster unless you think that the
current government is a complete
dysfunctional disaster it basically
means that although government will
continue to age and will never be young
and vigorous and extremely creative on
the other hand it will never be terribly
destructive and awful and will it be
able to keep it at least vigorous enough
to do the basic things we need to me
that's not so terrible so it's possible
for old democracies to age gracefully I
guess
I hope it is you know we're now the
oldest democracy in the world and that's
part of the reason we are where we are
and the good news is that we're doing
better than many other democracies that
are younger for instance we're doing a
much better job coping with our problems
than Japan is done because we're a more
open society a more open economy and we
have a more competitive government where
our states compete with each other and
with the federal government and
localities compete with the states and
all of those add some elements of
competition and flexibility which are on
our side and I'm optimistic that this
year is we see an electorate that's less
interested in kind of rabid government
bashing and more interested in sort of
pragmatic one step at a time candidates
like george w bush and an al gore that
we're seeing an electorate that's
becoming more willing to live with that
kind of incremental but nonetheless
useful kind of reform what is it like to
go from writing a column a weekly or do
you write a biweekly column i write a
biweekly column what's it like the
difference between writing a weekly or
bi-weekly column and a book boy you know
i write so many things in so many
different lengths that each piece has a
life of its own but a column of course
you look at what's going on that week
you look at what's in people's minds and
you try to try to address it and put it
in perspective and maybe bring a new
slant with the book you try to get
precisely above what's in people's minds
and you try to say wait a minute get
away from who's in the White House at
the moment get away from this notion of
gridlock just at present because the
Republicans have only a five or six seat
majority in the House who represented
think about the big picture look at the
long term and of course for a writer
there's there's no pleasure greater than
being able to stand really far back look
at the broad sweep of history and try to
make sense of it all I want if I can to
ask you a question about the language
that you employ throughout the book I'm
looking at page 24 and this is a
description again of mansur Olsen this
in the chapter mr. Olsen's planet I
wonder if you could just read a little
bit of this description of who he was
for us though he held a Harvard PhD in a
fancy title at the University of
Maryland even in his later years he
could still repair a tractor and he
midwestern matter-of-factness that made
his writing like his speech vigorous and
to the point yet an intellectual fire
burned in him he had a jumpy delighted
almost pick sheis excitability when he
talked about ideas he would ask visitors
to let him pace while he spoke and then
he prowled the way some people just
stick you late as though the movement
helped him form words the effect was
pleasently gnomish how much effort does
it take to create a description like
that I think it was John Kenneth
Galbraith or somebody who spoke of the
sense of spontaneity and natural
naturalness that comes in about the
sixteenth draft and I endorsed that
though sometimes I find that the first
draft is the best after all my advice
for a writer is revise revise revise
Jonathan Roush the book is government's
end why Washington stopped working it
was published by public affairs in 1999
thank you very much for coming in thank
you too a great pleasure